what is going on everybody welcome back
to my youtube channel richard on data
and if this is your first time here my
name is richard
and this is the channel where we talk
about all things data
data science statistics and programming
so subscribe for all kinds of content
just like this if you haven't already
and hit the notification bell so youtube
notifies you whenever i upload a video
so this is another video in my r
tutorial series
the last video in this series was all
about creating linear models
so you create some model object using an
lm or a glm function but okay
what exactly is the structure of that
object that you created
and then how do you extract useful
properties from it then i also covered
how you actually get these things into
more of a tidy format
using the broom package now one thing i
didn't really cover all that much in
that tutorial
was the interpretation side of things so
that's what we're going to talk about
today
so we're going to talk about the high
level idea
why you would want to use linear
regression or logistic regression
methods in the first place
and then once you've spun up these
functions using lm or glm
okay how do you actually interpret these
things so before we get started
hit the like button for the youtube
algorithm this script will be available
on my github repo
that's going to be linked in the
description of the video and now you can
watch
these tutorials in either order so if
you haven't watched our tutorial 10
i do recommend watching that one first
but it's not absolutely necessary
you can watch this one first but i'm
going to be working with
just like i did in that tutorial uh the
mt cars
and the credit card data sets for my
linear and logistic regression examples
and so the details of how i created
these and
why i did a few things that i did
beforehand are going to be available in
our tutorial 10.
so without further ado let's get started
alright so let's start with the high
level idea behind regression
what exactly is going on and why would
you want to do this in the first place
so regression methods are completely
analogous to that slope-intercept
equation
that you probably remember from back in
high school that is
y equals mx plus b and
what that equation basically means is
you're explaining the rise or the change
in some variable y
in terms of the run or the change in
some variable x
meanwhile you've got m that's your slope
term
and b that's your intercept term so
that's basically exactly what we're
doing when we do any kind of regression
method
so we're using these methods to fit a
linear model that explains the variation
in a response variable
sometimes called the dependent variable
linearly
in terms of other variables these are
typically known as the independent or
explanatory variables
i just call them predictors and so
you you you create a linear model which
is going to output some fitted values
y hat you have the actual values
that is the y and the idea is
we're using a least squares solution
now what that means is if you take that
difference
the difference between the actual and
the fitted values
we want the sum of all of those squared
differences
to be as small as possible that's the
least
squares solution and now i'm going to
give you the
matrix interpretation of this now
if you don't know linear algebra this
part may go over your head
but at least just be aware of the
notation
so the least squares equation for the
estimate of the slope parameters
that is beta hat equals x
transpose x all of that inverse
times x transpose times y
so again just be familiar with the
notation here
beta is the vector of true slope
parameters
for the whole population beta hat
is a vector containing the estimates of
the true slope parameters
that's the thing that we're that we're
trying to create here
x is your matrix of predictors
and y is the response vector so
most important thing here is the
predictors are typically going to be
denoted by
uh x is the matrix then x1 x2 x3
are the individual uh predictors and
then
y is your response vector now i really
want to emphasize one of the key
assumptions here
so take your response y and then just
pick any
predictor call that x1 so
the assumption is in the population at
large
there is a true slope parameter let's
call that
beta1 here that explains linearly
the variation in y in terms of a one
unit change in
x1 that's the assumption
now it's just like any other parameter
we can't truly know that slope parameter
but through linear regression we can
come up with an estimate for that slope
parameter
that's our estimate beta hat one
so that's a little bit different if you
have a bayesian interpretation
of statistics but the difference between
the frequentist interpretation and
bayesian interpretation
is completely the subject not even for
one more tutorial but for a whole other
series
but for how most people approach this
which is the frequent tested
interpretation
that's the true assumption on the back
end and so
you're going to get regression output
which is going to return
your estimates of these slope parameters
that is
let's just call that a vector beta hat
that's got
individual estimates beta hat 1 beta hat
2
so on and so forth naturally any
estimate or any statistic is going to
carry with it a corresponding standard
error
and then putting those things together
you can create a test statistic
and a p-value so the test statistic for
linear regression is a t-statistic
for logistic regression it's a
z-statistic and you're testing a
hypothesis of that true
corresponding slope parameter being
different
than zero so think about this if the
true slope parameter
is zero that means as x changes
y is not going to change so there's no
true relationship at least in a linear
sense
between these two variables now if that
null hypothesis
is false that is that true slope
parameter is not equal to zero
then that means as x changes y is going
to change
so that tells you there is actually some
kind of linear relationship
uh between these variables and that's
the hypothesis that we test we'll see
some examples when we look at
uh when we look at real output here now
i really do want to emphasize
there are two distinct goals that you
can get at with regression methods
and those are prediction and inference
now i have a whole video delineating the
difference between these two
so check that out if you haven't already
but at a high level
suppose you've created that regression
equation and then you just get new data
okay and in that new data let's say you
have values for all of your predictors
but you're missing that response well
you already have a full
linear equation that you can just plug
the predictors into
and then you're going to get predictions
for that response
so you can use this completely for
predicting that response
it's typically going to underperform
things like traditional
uh machine learning methods but all the
same
i mean it can be used and you have the
benefit of just
interpretability and understanding
exactly where
uh your prediction is coming from now
again completely distinct from that
is the fact that regression methods can
be used for inference
and i've already explained at a high
level exactly what's going on
but the idea is these estimates of slope
parameters
are used to estimate how much the
response variable will change
per one unit increase in each continuous
explanatory variable
or per change in levels in the
categorical variables
and so we'll see examples of that once
we look at the actual output
so i'm going to run the exact same
regression that i did in our tutorial
number 10
and again you can go over to that one
for the for the details
but i'm going to go through and
interpret for you every piece
of this output so we start out with the
model call
all that is that is that's just the
function that's getting run in r
then the next thing that we have are the
residuals now the residuals are just the
difference between the observed values
that is the actual y's and the predicted
values or the fitted values that is the
y-hat
and now this is a very similar idea
to the fact that the slope estimates
that we calculate
they are estimating true parameters true
slope parameters
and these residuals are just statistics
which estimate
true population errors so just keep that
in mind
now there's an assumption on the back
end with regression that these true
population
errors are normally distributed with a
mean
equal to zero and constant standard
deviation
that is there's no real pattern to the
true population errors
and you can do things like just graph
out your residuals to test how valid
that assumption is
moving on the real meat and potatoes of
the regression output is this
coefficient table here
and so what we've got here are the
estimates of the slope parameters
every statistic or estimate is going to
carry with it a standard error
so those values are reported here as
well and again we've got t
values and corresponding p values
and so again for the most part here what
we've got for continuous variables is
the estimate and how much we expect y to
change
for a one unit change in that
corresponding
x variable now there are a couple
differences here
and so i want to draw attention here to
some specific
uh special cases so let's take
this dis variable here so i did a
transformation when i created this
uh this linear regression equation here
i'm modeling
the response variable mpg in terms of
the square root
of this disp variable now it's still
pretty straightforward
for a one unit change or one unit
increase specifically
in the square root of the disp variable
i expect mpg to change by
negative 0.0732 okay
not that much to it now another thing i
do want to draw attention to
is the fat is categorical variables or
factor variables
and an example of that is the cyl
variable here
so it's important to understand with
these factors
when you look at these slope estimates
here these are with respect
to a baseline so this cyl variable
it takes on values 4 6 or 8.
now your baseline here is four
so let's just assume here that we have a
car with cyl
equals eight now if we hold all other
variables constant
we expect that car with cyl equals eight
to have mpg of .09762
greater than the car with the baseline
cyl equals
four okay so again most important
thing to understand with these factor
variables is these estimates are just
compared to some baseline now the last
thing to draw your attention to is this
interaction term here
so generally when we add terms to this
linear regression equation
we are assuming that the the cumulative
effect
of all these things is additive
but we change that assumption around
when we add interaction terms
so there's an interaction term here
between the variables
hp and weight that is wt
so let's just assume we have one unit
increases
in hp and wt okay we would then
expect mpg to change by negative 0.10267
plus that is negative 8.25722
and then plus 0.02657
so again if these things are both
increasing the net
effect of that on our response variable
is not necessarily additive
now let's just quickly touch on these t
statistics here and these p
values so you'll notice that next to the
intercept term
as well as hp wt and this interaction
term
that these p-values are starred this
means they're significant
at a particular level of significance
for this example let's just say 0.05
so remember we are testing against a
null hypothesis
that these individual slope parameters
are equal to zero
since these p-values are lower than 0.05
in this case we are rejecting these null
hypotheses
so we can conclude these true slope
parameters
are different than zero meaning in the
population at large
there is a statistically significant
effect that these
that these variables have on our
response variable mpg
now statistically significant does not
necessarily mean the same thing as
practically significant
that's a whole uh other can of worms
there
but that's the interpretation behind
these t statistics and the corresponding
p
values now let's wrap up with these last
few terms at the bottom here
so starting with residual standard error
this is a super important quantity
now this is an estimate of the standard
deviation of the true population errors
but think of it analogously as how wrong
the model is on average so
it's also in the case of linear
regression it's equal to the quantity
root mean squared error and when your
goal is prediction
this is a really good goal post for the
quality of your model
now the lower this thing is obviously
the better
because that's telling you your model is
less wrong
on average uh the lower this thing gets
moving on we've got multiple r squared
this is a quantity known as the
coefficient of determination
and this is the proportion of the
variation in the response variable
that can be explained by this linear
regression model that we're using
so very important quantity we're
basically saying
89.3 percent of the variation
in this mpg variable is explained by
this model that we've built
but there is one very important drawback
to this
quantity which is as we add more
predictors
this thing is either going to stay the
same or it's going to keep going
up and up and up having said that adding
more predictors
is not necessarily a good thing because
it means you're just going to create
a regression model that over fits so to
correct for this problem
you've also got this quantity called
adjusted r
squared so this corrects for this issue
and the formula for it can be seen here
adjusted r squared equals
1 minus then in parenthesis 1 minus r
squared
times n minus 1 all over n minus p minus
1 where
n is the total sample size and p
is the number of predictors and
basically what's going on here is
this quantity penalizes additional
predictors
so we're balancing here explaining all
the variation
in our y variable with how much are we
overfitting how complicated are we
making this model
lastly we've got this f statistic and
now
interestingly suppose we had only one
predictor in the model
actually that f statistic would just be
equal to the square
of that corresponding t statistic but
generally speaking this isn't really
something you have to worry about that
much
you are testing whether or not the
linear regression model fits the data
better than a model with no predictors
notice that we have an extremely low p
value here
as we expect so again a high f statistic
and a corresponding low p
value would just indicate the model does
fit the data better
than a model with no predictors now this
is again
not something that you have to worry
about all that much that covers it for
linear regression and now we're going to
move on to logistic regression
so the key difference between the two is
that with
linear regression we had a continuous
response variable
now with logistic regression we have a
categorical
response variable now the thing with
logistic regression
when most people talk about it they're
specifically referring to binomial
logistic regression
that is the case where your response
variable
is a categorical variable with two
levels
typically we're going to refer to those
as success and failure
or one and zero where you've got a
probability of success
that's equal to p and then your
corresponding probability of failure
is equal to one minus p now
a term just to understand the theory
here at a high level to be familiar with
is odds now that's a ratio of the
relative probabilities
that is p divided by one minus
p so for instance suppose i'm rolling a
six sided die
the probability that i'm gonna land on a
six
is one over six but these odds here
are actually one over six divided by
five over six that is one over five
so another key assumption here
just to be familiar with is the fact
that with linear regression
your continuous variable could go all
the way from negative infinity
to infinity so that's obviously not the
case with probabilities or with odds
you're gonna go from zero to one however
what goes on with logistic regression is
you get around that issue
by taking a transformation known as the
log
odds of the probability so the log odds
is just
the natural log of p divided by 1 minus
p
and this quantity here the log odds is
sometimes known as the
the logit and so our logistic regression
equation
is just natural the logic of p
equals same thing as it did before we've
got all of our x variables
and we've got corresponding slope
estimates to them
so logistic regression is significantly
more technically and mathematically
complex than linear regression
but the high level idea behind it all
the same
most stakeholders are going to
understand
now one concept that i want to introduce
here at at least a high level
and again this may go over your head a
little bit if you don't
know statistics too much already but
just be familiar with the terminology at
a very high level
is the deviance so the deviance is
defined as
the degree to which the likelihood
that's again a statistical concept
of the saturated model exceeds the
likelihood
of the model that we're creating here
where the saturated model
is just a model with as many parameters
as you have observations
that is a perfect fit type of model
so just at a very high level just
understand
the lower the deviance that we have the
better
the higher quality of fit that we have
so
again i'm going to create the exact same
logistic regression model that i did in
our tutorial number 10
and now let's look at the output here
first thing you've got
under the model call is the deviance
residuals
and these are completely analogous to
the residuals that you saw from linear
regression
every deviance residual corresponds to
an observation
and how much it contributed to the total
deviance
that is the variation from the perfect
fit that's all you've got to understand
with that
we've got this coefficient table here
and again it's got a very
similar sort of interpretation to the
linear regression coefficient table
we've got a linear equation going on on
the back end
so let's just take for example the
income variable here
notice that there's a slope estimate
here of 0.34592
so for a one unit increase in the income
variable
we expect the log odds of the success
of a response variable here that is a
credit
card being issued we expect the log odds
of that to go up by
0.34592
now you can do a conversion there to see
how the probability changes
from unit to unit but at its highest
level
just understand that if you have a
positive coefficient here
then then as income increases we do
expect the probability of our response
variable
the credit card being issued to go up as
well
then lastly we have some more metrics
indicating the quality of the model fit
so starting with this null deviance
that's generally not something you're
going to have to worry about
that is the deviance in the situation
where you have a model
containing only the intercept so
you would expect the model with only an
intercept term
is not going to fit very well as a
result you're going to have a very high
deviance and meanwhile you've got the
residual deviance
which indicates the goodness of fit for
the model that we created
now we expect this to be much lower
if we have a good model than the null
deviance
so in this case that appears to be the
case
now then you've got aic so aic
is also a quantity that you can get from
linear regression
this stands for the akiki information
criterion
and this is just another metric that
describes the quality of the model fit
and it's a pretty nice quantity because
this is another
quantity that increases as parameters
are added
and having a higher aic is a bad
thing so lower the aic
the better of a model fit that you have
you're also provided the number of
fisher scoring iterations
all this is is the number of iterations
that it took for the model to converge
for most people that's not going to be
particularly interesting
so that just about covers it for linear
and logistic regression
just to provide you a high level
introduction to the output that you get
from r and then how do you interpret all
this
now this is an incredibly broad field
you can get into things like model
selection weighting the models
other types of generalized linear models
so there's a
ton of depth to this field but it all
starts with
having a clear understanding of these
things and being able to explain it to
stakeholders
so just start there master it and then
move from there
so i'll leave you all with that thanks
for watching this video
if you enjoyed it hit the like button
consider sharing
and then i'll see you all in the not so
distant future until then
richard on data